does it make oh yes they love this 2015
party his thought was a party and my
absolute favorite song would have to be
into the New World
cuz that's what it started the story is
for everyone about finally being
comfortable in your own skin I wanted to
bring all the things I loved about kpop
and all the things I loved about the pop
I grew up to and for an album
yes I'm hoping to continuously put up
music and hopefully have a body of work
to share for my fans
[Music]
there was like fantastic friends here
were like we can call him Danny packs
sounds like oh my god no but there are
some really really fun and creative
names so I'm really looking forward to
what the fans come up with so let me
know what you guys they don't say fanny
pack I'm a huge fan of the Lionheart
Talk Talk because I had a lot of input
on that all of that song I looked so
much that I performed at my solo concert
like on an acoustic version sorry to
disappoint but nope actually they said
if she doesn't pick the Lionheart top
top we don't know her so yes you do know
me
[Music]
at or out face and then feel like
everybody's like yes I was not the pink
we thought we were getting and then it
was like fluorescent almost obnoxious
pink I mean everything is a challenge
but growing up in front of the camera my
band mates tonight we're talking about
so anything and then they're like wow we
cooked really well and I was like yeah
pat on the back - everybody's going up
would probably be one of the toughest
things but I'm here at this interview I
made it I feel like I'd probably be
doing the art side or the
behind-the-scenes side to music or
fashion or or puppies I guess I'm
getting both worlds where I get to come
here and say I'm thinking in Korean
because it I was always thinking in
English when I was in Korea but I guess
I'm flexing both muscle
[Music]
my secret is having just as comfortable
shoes when I'm off of them and balancing
cuz you can guess it's unreal my
choreographers in real mine control
oh my gosh I look so creepy say about
wait so does that make me professor Eric
yeah thank you call me professor T
little mermaid is everything because
morals and values were built on Disney
you know being in a world where you
think you had everything and everyone
tells you that you should thought you
should believe what they're saying but
you believe in a bigger world and you go
out of your comfort zone for love and I
think that's an amazing story and it's
ironic because I'm scared of fish eyes
weird right no side eyes fell from
aerial
I pushed it because you love all of them
but I did get to meet Victoria Beckham
she told me about she said that being in
a girl band is amazing you create family
from that and I was like you're right I
love all of you yes I love them all
it was during their interview I was like
yeah you need to see her and she's like
I'm not that desperate and it was a joke
but I guess the fans love when we say
like pretty intense keyword and that's
why they're like yeah
Tansen desperate and she posted a
support post on my song she put like
every pink emoji there was and that
takes a lot of time at heart and then
the fans are like yeah totally that's
right I was like no she just loves me we
love each other yes we are desperate for
each other
does that clear these adorable puppies
are available for adoption at the Animal
Society check out their website at
that's friend spot away
[Music]